in a previous video we introduced
ourselves to the idea of average atomic
mass which we began to realize could be
a very useful way of thinking about a
mass at an atomic level or at a
molecular level but we're to do in this
video is connect it to the masses that
we might actually see in a chemistry lab
you're very unlikely to just be dealing
with one atom or just a few atoms or
just a few molecules you're more likely
to deal with several grams of an actual
substance so how do we go from the
masses at an atomic scale to the masses
masses of samples that you see in an
actual chemistry lab or and I guess you
could say our scale of the world
well the chemistry community has come up
with a useful tool they said alright
let's think about a given element so say
lithium we know it's average atomic mass
is six point nine four six point nine
for unified atomic mass units per atom
atom of lithium what if there were a
certain number of atoms of lithium such
that if I have that number so times
certain certain number of atoms then I
will actually end up with six point nine
four grams grams of lithium and this
number of atoms is six point zero two to
one four zero seven six times ten to the
23rd power so if you have a sample with
this number of lithium atoms that sample
is going to have a mass of six point
nine four grams whatever its average
atomic mass is in terms of unified
atomic mass units if you have that
number of the atom you will have a mass
of that same number in terms of grams
now you might be saying is there a name
for this number and there is indeed a
name and it is called Avogadro's number
named in honor of the early 19th century
Italian
chemist amedeo avogadro and in most
contexts because you're not normally
dealing with data with this many
significant digits we will usually
approximate it as 6.0 to 2 times 10 to
the 23rd power now there's another word
that it's very useful to familiarize
yourself with in chemistry and that's
the idea of a mole now what is a mole it
is not a little mark on your cheek it is
not a burrowing animal actually it is
both of those things but in a chemistry
context a mole is just saying you have
this much of something the word mole was
first used by the German chemist Wilhelm
Ostwald at the end of the 19th century
and he came up with the word because of
its relation to molecule now what does
that mean well think about the word
dozen if I say I've got a dozen of eggs
how many eggs do I have well if I have a
dozen of eggs that means I have 12 eggs
so if I say I have a mole of lithium
atoms how many lithium atoms do I have
that means that I have 6.022 one four
zero seven six times ten to the 23rd
lithium atoms exact same idea it's just
that Avogadro's number is a much hairier
of a number than a dozen so let's use
our newfound powers of the mole and
Avogadro's number to start doing some
useful things let's say that someone
were to walk up to you and say hey you I
have a fifteen point four milligram
sample of germanium how many atoms of
germanium am i dealing with pause this
video and try to think about that so let
me clear out some space the periodic
table of elements was taking up all
right so we started off with fifteen
point four milligrams of germanium the
first step might be hey let's convert
this to gray
of germanium and so we can do a little
bit of dimensional analysis we can just
multiply this for every one gram of
germanium that is equivalent to one
thousand milligrams milligrams of
germanium and so if you essentially
multiply by one thousandth or divide by
a thousand we're gonna get the grams of
germanium and you could see that in the
dimensional analysis by seeing that that
is going to cancel out with that leaving
us with just the grams of germanium and
now that we have an expression for grams
of germanium we could think about moles
of germanium so how do we do that well
we're going to multiply by some quantity
and in the denominator we're going to
want grams of germanium for the
dimensional analysis to work out grams
of germanium and in the numerator we
want the new expression to be in terms
of moles of germanium so one mole of
germanium is equal to how many grams of
germanium well we see it right over here
germanium molar mass is seventy two
point six three grams per mole so for
every mole we have seventy two point six
three grams of germanium and you can see
that the units work out these grams of
germanium are going to cancel with the
grams of germanium just leaving us with
moles of germanium and in actual
chemistry practice finding out the moles
of a substance might actually be the
most useful thing but if you wanted to
find out the actual atoms of germanium
that we're dealing with we will just
multiply by the number of atoms you have
per mole and this is going to be true
for any element for every mole you have
Avogadro's number of atoms and we're
going to approximate that as 6.022 times
ten to the 23rd atoms atoms of germanium
for every one mole mole of germanium and
so just to review what we just did we
had milligrams of germanium you multiply
these two together you'll have grams of
germanium which makes sense you're
essentially just dividing by a thousand
if you were to multiply your grams of
germanium times the mole
per gram which is really just the
reciprocal of this molar mass we got
here and just to make sure where it
makes sense the units work out nice
through the dimensional analysis this
right over here tells you your moles
moles of germanium and then if you take
your moles and then you multiply it by
Avogadro's number it tells you how many
atoms of germanium we have and that
makes sense if if I told you I had a
certain number of dozen of eggs if I
want to know how many eggs that is I
would multiply by 12 so this whole
expression is the number of atoms atoms
of germanium so we have 15 point 4
milligrams if we want to figure out how
many grams we have we then divide that
by a thousand that's what our
dimensional analysis tells us and it
also makes logical sense divided by a
thousand so this is how many grams we
have and then if we want to figure out
how many moles and it's going to be a
small fraction of a mole because a mole
is 72 point 6 3 grams per mole we have a
small fraction of a gram much less 72
point 6 3 grams and so we saw from our
analysis to figure out the number of
moles we're now we're going to
essentially divide by seventy two point
six 3 so divided by 72 point six 3 is
equal to this is the number of moles of
germanium we have and if we want to
figure out the number of atoms of
germanium well then multiply that times
Avogadro's number so times 6.022 times
10 to the 23rd and this ie button means
times 10 to the OEE 23rd power so that's
how you do it on a calculator and then
that gives us this many atoms and let's
see just to get our significant digits
here our significant figures out of all
of the things we multiplied see we had 4
significant digits here the four
significant digits here but we only had
3 over here
so I'm going to round to three
significant digits so I'll go to one
point two eight times 10 to the 20th
atoms so we have approximately one point
two eight times 10 to the 20th atoms
of germanium which is a lot